foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
NBA bets you love the crew is all back
what up fellas how we doing uh hey you
guys might know we are in the middle of
the playoffs we are in the middle of the
playoffs so I gotta know I want to know
how you guys doing how you guys uh
fairing off with these playoffs in bed
starting off with you Ryan
yeah I mean I would definitely feel
better if Trey young didn't ruin my life
last night
I'm just honest with you
yeah brain last night because like oh
the Celtics are up big like the game's
over and then I was outside a bar window
watching because I was like on my phone
and then I was like oh my God I gotta go
run to a TV and I watched it from
outside a window uh and there's no way
there's no worse way to watch your team
lose than that cold and on the street
unbelievable that was brutal that shot
was crazy too MB your team got bounced
early on but how's your beds doing
bets are doing good man uh sorry I'm
gonna apologize for my scratchy voice I
got back from Vegas recently but I got
my tea no load management for me I'm
playing hurt uh the playoffs have been
awesome man I got I got Futures on the
Suns
um I think that they're gonna have to
get some more bench production if they
actually want to win a title but it's
been fun man all these games have been
really really fun to watch and that's
what you want for the first round right
all of these games have been really
really fun to watch and my man this is
my man's Bolens flu show so shout out to
my man Bowman and the food show if you
guys are in the comments I need sick
emojis in the comments uh but uh Hey
today's slate guys today slate is pretty
Immaculate like I like today slate four
games today uh but the best one oh sorry
Ryan what Eddie's Eddie slate with the
New York Knicks on it I hard to say
Immaculate hard to say Immaculate I mean
the way they've been playing though the
way they've been playing they you know
they've been shining a light in the in
New York City I think the lights been
blue and uh blue and orange out there
right they asked for the Mets and we've
been playing well
that ain't for the Knicks
ah but yeah
exciting games today you guys know the
last game of the day is going to be the
most exciting it's those Golden State
Warriors gonna go get it going in
Sacramento right how are you how are you
guys doing man how are you guys doing we
don't want to know like like Ryan I I
wish we could play a clip from
previously you know like when you were
talking about the town of Sacramento and
how it wasn't a real City but now you're
like full-fledged oh it's a it's a
village now yeah it's a village it's
been down for it's slowly growing but
now you're just all over the Kings right
no I love them now I love them now
listen I am guilty there there were
people in this office uh hand up that uh
you know may have caught me saying it's
over after the deer and Fox News I did
I'll owed up to that I did say it was
over and then the man said no matter
what I'm playing
and then I said we're back and I feel
good I feel good we'll get to that game
we've got a whole slate going we gotta
don't you worry we'll get we'll get
there we definitely will get to that
game uh let me welcome you guys to the
show everybody that just joined welcome
to the show my name is Greg Ivory above
me up there is the man we like to call
producer Ryan and below me but he's
still my guy he's not nothing nothing
below we're even my it's my boy MB May
he's just beneath me right now you guys
can see him uh but hey we are here
please drop your Best Bets in the chat
make sure you guys drop your Best Bets
in the chat we're talking nakes Cavs
Lakers Grizzlies Heat Bucks in those
Golden State Warriors taking on the
Sacramento Kings uh Ryan talk to us what
is the audience talking about in the
chat uh right now I see n Schwartz
dropped Jarrett Vanderbilt over five and
a half and then Dilo over 14 and a half
here's might here's my my early concerns
my early concerns as we start the show
because we have a 30 minute journey
ahead of us
um yeah I don't know what those numbers
are in reference to five and a half what
14 and a half what
I mean we've been doing this show long
enough
I'm assuming they mean points uh I
wonder though
is it is Jared Vanderbilt's number
really five and a half points because
that's pretty low that's two threes
I don't see Jared Vanderbilt on the
board yeah that
five and a half
I see a little sketchy
but yeah
and Ryan said when you guys are filling
up those comments filling up the chat
please please please be as specific as
you can just because we want to ride
with you we want to talk about what you
guys are talking about go ahead that was
such a nicer way that was such a nicer
way of saying when I when I say I'm
yelling at everybody I'm fired up
we have some interesting plays in here
today and I think it's worth mentioning
because we got four games and it's a
four leg parlay so we've got uh xvso
said Lakers money line and warriors
money line and then Dr Chico Suave
that's a good one that's a good one uh
said Giannis double double now the thing
with the honest double double is we
could take that but we can't take
another play from that game because we
can't same game parlay it so wait before
we before we start the parlay yes can
you check what that double double
actually is because we need a squad ride
for tonight that doesn't sound like a
bad play usually usually this is like a
minus 800 deal I hope it's not because
if it ain't maybe he's like what's that
we need a squat ride for today let's see
if we can dig let's see if we can get
two birds and one stone oh it's minus
360. that's my leg though that is a leg
that's what I'm saying I like this for
sure that's a leg for sure I I think
like one yeah and listen the the point
the spread in this game is 12 I think
it's too much I do like the Bucks minus
12 but that's a hard one to get behind
um so I think we just take this one we
leave this game alone and then we go we
go elsewhere I agree yeah I totally
agree uh I also Ryan I'm in the comments
I see LeBron double double I don't want
to butcher this guy's name Dr Chi Dr Chi
Dr Chi says LeBron double double that's
Dr Chico Suave oh Dr Chico Suave I'm not
saying rock with that but I'm just
throwing ideas out there
Greg you like that for the squad ride
LeBron double double
Gotta Give up this squad ride stuff man
let's see let's see go go go let's see
the numbers we got to see what the
numbers are MB
minus 140
you officially become the squad ride
legend of the night that will be
programmed as soon as this show is over
are we doing it for this though
no no we got a parlay to build
oh we can put it in a parlay
we can't have the double double in the
parlay
brother look at this Plus 119.
is this a separate parlay from our show
parlay no this is the show on the show
bowling what do you mean
what is this okay
two leg parlay we're done we just get
out of here in seven minutes no we got
two more legs
you can combine this with other stuff
yes just not from the same game so the
Lakers game is out and the Bucks game is
out oh my God you just blew my mind I'm
getting the vibe guys I'm getting a vibe
from the comments
every game
yes
I see it in the comments I also see
jiren Jackson Double-Double so we got to
choose between Jaron Jackson and LeBron
James who do we think is going to get
that double double oh wait
oh wait this is tough I also don't want
to blow up our spot here
um but blow it up
Jared and Jared Jackson blocks has oh
easy go see what it is
bro it's been easy but it's in the same
game though no I know I'm saying we're
gonna have to we might have to oh uh
we'd have to eliminate LeBron
that's what I was saying is it's gonna
have to be either one to be honest
though Ryan that over two and a half
Blocks he's gonna have that in the first
quarter I feel like all right all right
now and I gotta
now now the game's in Memphis yo yo yo
yo yo guys I don't know if you guys
remember but there was like a a rumor
going around that in Memphis they pad
his block statistics Google it oh
scoop that's what we call scoop
come on we like this do we want to do it
so wait no go ahead so we're gonna take
we're gonna let LeBron be the squad ride
we'll let Dr Chico Suave have his moment
of shine and not you know mess with our
parlay here so we could take that out
and then
do we want to take his regular over two
and a half blocks or do we want to go
four plus blocks
come on I say get spicy hello man right
come on man crazy bro I'm crazy
what about three like I feel like three
is fair because well that's over two and
a half
yeah
is the odds different though minus one
two yeah it is yeah yeah
let's just I just want to see I just
want to see okay go ahead go ahead
Boss 3 21.
you're an animal dude Ryan I mean if
we're considering that what was his
numbers in the I mean I can look it up I
gotta know what was his numbers in like
the last couple games in order for me to
like even Ponder him getting four blocks
let me see five blocks then and he went
five blocks zero blocks three blocks two
blocks in this series
five blocks what was it zero five zero
three two okay we forget about It's
gotta be three let's just stay it gotta
be three three
okay so we want to add in Anthony Davis
three plus blocks I saw that from
somebody in here who said it wait but we
can't use it because it's in the same
game bowling bowling bowling bowling I'm
here man I'm here bowling he's here this
is Ryan remember remember this is my flu
show I'm losing my mind
hey I like how he picked up the cup this
is bowling's flu shot oh my God yes we
need to add Anthony Davis in this uh
Ryan you want me to go over his numbers
in the series as far as in blocks oh I
know he's swatting him left and right
but if you just want to say it so we can
brag I mean this is for the this is for
the people four blocks three blocks five
blocks seven blocks let's go
those is all his block totals over the
series I like that Ryan that's a great
call Bro great call
yeah I this is I like this we're
cracking now dude we're good we're
cooking up man we're cooking up I'm
gonna say something but shut it down if
you guys don't want to do it do we want
to do
JJJ two plus blocks Anthony Davis four
plus blocks
oh that's interesting how much more how
much more value do we get out of it I
think they both get three pretty easily
and we would hate for
yeah just check
it's about the same right yeah it's
about the same so no I say we just go
three and three okay yeah three or three
plays safe
all right okay so now we need one more
leg
um Darien's in here oh Darien who's 80s
dealing with the with the hip injury
Darion nah he played after that I saw
what he's talking about he just grabbed
his hip a little bit but then he
continued to play so
I think he'll be good all right let's go
get him he's young he's spry
okay oh that's the problem he's young
and spry and he somehow is never on the
court but he's fine we're right he's 80
versus Street closes the it's a rivalry
of our Our Generation unfortunately
him in Kauai yeah
um all right we need one more we need
one more play uh we did not touch the
Knicks game and we also did not touch
the Golden State Warriors Kings game uh
which way are we leaning Ryan do you see
anybody in the comments giving us a lien
which way are you leaning bowling feel
free to hop in if you got a scoop from
the app
yeah no uh l-e L Edwards 98 says next
Cavs under 212 every game but one has
hit that under
interesting I think this is gonna be a
tight one the Cavs backs against the
wall I don't think this this game is
going to be super high scoring you add
10 points to that total I'd be
comfortable with that
yeah I I don't hate it I also we got a a
pretty good comment here from uh to Mark
to Mark omelette
omelette I don't I don't know if that's
how you say it but uh the Aaron Fox uh
underpoints didn't drop a specific
number but the man's got a broken finger
he does have a broken finger okay my
only pushback on this
my only pushback on this is like the
Aaron Fox is really a dog in my opinion
and I don't know if he's gonna have a
great game but I don't think it's gonna
affect him like if he couldn't play he
wouldn't play
yeah I think he might be all right I'm
like we would be so pissed if we faded
him because we thought he was hurt and
then he goes off for 30.
I take with that boy
he wasn't making a lot of them in this
series bowling in this series my man's
been draining the MIDI he's been
draining the three now I think with a
splint on his finger something that he
hasn't been you know playing with
something that he isn't really
accustomed to
I just don't think that he's gonna make
the same shots that he was making
but his total is only 24 and a half like
my guy he's capable of getting to the
cup getting fouled you know what I'm
saying and going there like he might be
comfortable at the free throw line
versus like versus like jumpers you know
now if we do like under 30 points I
don't think he's getting 30. that's a
lockety lock lock but you know you know
Ryan likes value Ryan likes value and I
don't think that the value will be up to
Ryan's then my my only thing here is
like I feel like we're looking at this
very one-dimensionally like he he has a
broken finger that's a fact the best
part about the Aaron Fox's game is
scoring I think if he's playing he's
going to want to do that something else
is going to have to be a little bit more
deficient than it usually is and I don't
know if that's rebounds and I don't know
if that's a CIS and I don't know if you
guys necessarily have a lien but the
Sacramento Kings are not known for
playing defense so I don't necessarily
hate us shifting over to rebounds and
trying to figure out something there
not with him specifically I just I can't
see him getting dirty I agree he's not
gonna go up there and risk his finger
trying to grab you know what I'm saying
like that's not his game yeah come on
that's not his game I would agree with
that he's going to be what is it it's
over under four and a half
yeah do we want to see oh my God I like
that right now
bro that puts us at plus 600. that's a
good thing
I know we gotta let me just check this
for a second he in the games with a
healthy finger has had nine rebounds
nine rebounds five rebounds one rebound
we could I mean we're at plus 600 if we
want to bump it up to five and a half
but again yeah bump it up to five and a
half my man's been getting nine rebounds
and his lines at four and a half I feel
like that should tell you enough of the
story somebody knows yeah
I feel like it's going to be a tough
game for dear and fox today draymond's
going to be guarding him he's going to
have a stint on his finger
I don't think he's really gonna try to
go grab those rebounds so I like this
play
I really do
we got sonoa 42 in the chat saying Fox
rebounds should be green
yes sir thank you
yeah okay we're at plus four to Twenty
Eight
we locked in the under what five and a
half or six and a half five and a half
five and a half we could lock in under
six and a half and add one more Super
Lucky leg
I don't know just up to you guys I don't
know what you guys think but I feel like
every everything we put in here is
hitting
I know but I feel that way every week
I think we have
[Laughter]
this this is the one like to be honest
okay right like I think this I think
this is the one and I I really want to
win you know I'm sick of listening to
the haters
me too I want to win too you hear you
hear a lot from the haters Ryan so I'm
sure you do want to hear less from them
the haters have to be on speed dial yeah
like no joke bro I was getting phone
calls like what where is these coming
from anyways let's let are we locking
this in though right let's let's ask the
chat for thumbs up maybe yeah
all right all right everybody in the
chat that is uh here riding with us we
want to let actually Ryan I'm so sorry
before we go thumbs up thumbs down let's
say what the parlay is and then let's
ask them thumbs up thumbs down so go
ahead do what we love
do what you do best Ryan yeah yeah this
is Reed uh yeah it's double double uh
Jared Jackson three plus blocks Anthony
Davis three plus blocks and de'arron fox
under five and a half rebounds four legs
plus four three five there it is there
it is if you guys are rocking with it we
need thumbs up if you guys are not
rocking with it we need thumbs down in
the chat but in between time between
time uh
Dub's getting the W today guys I just I
just had to let that be known
um but dear and fox Ryan I think you
found something this this leg right here
with the rebounds of Deanna Fox
this might be something this might be a
lockety lock lock I think so too I feel
a little uh
this is what the sharps feel like I
think you know what I mean
self-proclaimed there's a lot of there's
a lot of things involved with the with
the with that kind of handicap though
like you were thinking through it was a
stream of Consciousness you really loved
those kind of Vibes you let it flow like
water Ryan for the first time I think I
think you learned something this year
we've been doing this show for five
months for the first time
okay so I'm starting to see some thumbs
up Ryan's letting it flow on the show
this is bolin's flu show and uh I'm
starting to see some some thumbs up in
the chat so I'm I'm starting to lean
towards uh locking this one in I guess
it's locked baby let's go let's lock it
in if you guys lock it in before
everybody figures it out you gotta lock
it in before they figure out I like that
bowling man I like that don't lock it
before they figure out man make sure
y'all lock in before the others figure
out make sure y'all get some money with
us because we are we're going to the
window with this one I I got a good
feeling if you guys want to tell our
four leg parlay make sure you head on
over to FanDuel but before you guys do
that Ryan tell the people what's
happening yeah I said this last week if
you've just been watching this for Vibes
which I don't blame you because the
Vibes have been immaculate uh but all of
a sudden you're like oh I want to go I
want to go you know make a bet I want to
tail these guys or I want to fade these
guys wouldn't blame you uh new customers
bet five bucks get a hundred and fifty
dollars back and bonus bets guaranteed
150 150 is enough for you to come back
again Taylor's fade us and then get rich
next week so go do it all you gotta do
is BET five dollars and you get 150.
just like that if only it was that easy
right come on man everybody's got five
dollars hey you can flip that hundred
and fifty into a three team par laying
you feel you walk away with some some
you don't talk about but uh
some people got that some people didn't
I hope you did because you tell me I'm
trying to win
hahaha
hey but let's talk best best for tonight
let's talk best best for tonight
uh let's start off with Ryan you're up
top might as well start off for us uh
what is your best bet for tonight yeah
I'm bowling just to you know follow up
on that I don't know if you've been
seeing my bets recently I wouldn't I
wouldn't say if everyone has five
dollars okay I wouldn't say that
not a guarantee are you admitting that
you're broke on on like a live show
that's crazy I'm admitting that Major
League Baseball is robbing me of cash
yes
good thing we're betting on the NBA
tonight baby yeah yeah this is the time
to get back okay
my best bet
the Milwaukee Bucks to trail by 15
points and come back and win I think
this is a game that everyone expects
Miami
to
or I'm sorry expects Milwaukee to come
in and smack around Miami and get back
in the series
I think Milwaukee gets back in the
series but I think there's going to be
some severe scary hours here for fans
Bettors of the bucks
um the Bucks are done they're cooked
it's over there they will lose this
series but tonight I think they go down
by 15 and then they come back and you
get that at 15-1 15-1 we have we don't
give out bets at 15-1 on this show
he just gave out a parlay that oh it
wasn't 15. you're right bro bro
yeah you're right you're right but Ryan
I mean love the I mean
like the bet I'm in support of what you
got yeah you almost said I love but I
just want to know I just want to know
this one counts towards your record
right because no don't say that your
best bet this letter this segment's
called now Best Bets for tonight and you
come and drop a 15 to one so I just want
to know this counts towards your record
right I did want to clarify this we had
we had a meeting earlier about the the
best bet segment and I wanted to say
we're not I'm not calling it the best
bet segment this is void this is best
bet void for Ryan for you guys if you
guys want to count it this this does not
count so annoying man
uh MB we're I'm Gonna Let You Go last
I'm gonna jump in here I saw this very
exciting exciting bet on FanDuel and it
caught my eyes uh it's dunk in the first
three minutes
I'm gonna look at the Lakers Memphis
Grizzlies game we got a lot of High
Flyers we got LeBron James Anthony Davis
uh John Moran JJ all right we got a lot
of people that likes the slam the ball
so uh I'm gonna go one plus dump
I think it's in quick bets
thank you bowling there it is is that
one plus dunk in the first three minutes
that's when I'm rocking with I'm rocking
with one dunk all I need is one dunk in
the first three minutes of this high
flying game I think the Memphis
Grizzlies are gonna try to come out with
the Vengeance I mean they went to LA you
know they lost a couple games they're
gonna try to come out come out fast I'm
gonna see my man John Moran trying to
set the tone throwing the alley-oop to
uh Jaron Jaren Jaren Jackson Jr so uh
I'm rocking with one plus dunk in the
first three minutes MB I know you've
been having this thing with first
baskets and you hit you hit some too uh
talk to us is that what you're leaning
towards or are you going a different way
I'm keeping it consistent uh I'm
actually going to be in the same game uh
we're talking Grizzlies we're talking
Lakers my best bet tonight
and I'm nervous because this is too
volatile but I've been rocking with the
big man
A.D had a pretty rough game offensively
last time out and he was getting crushed
on the post game shows and they still
won LeBron knows that they got to get
him going if they want to close this out
on the road so I'm rocking with my man
from Chicago
in the A.D got the all-star jersey from
Chicago
let me get A.D listen it's really not
that hard he's got to win a tip
and just back down uh Jaren Jackson Jr
you don't have to dunk it on him just
back them down do the little fade away
and we're good to go five to one
this guy scored first baskets for them
all season long
LeBron's gonna throw it to him in the
post he's gonna get it done
and raise go ahead
yes Ryan are we okay if
Jaron Jackson blocks him but he gets the
ball back and then puts it back in or do
we need it to be super smooth
that sounds fine to me it could be like
a block and then he gets the little baby
tap in whatever but it's just before he
goes up basket yeah he goes up and it
gets swatted into like the sixth row of
the crowd but then they pass it back
into A.D he backs them down and gets a
little revenge for the first basket yeah
for the SWAT
not gonna say I have the script but
it sure sounds like you have the script
buddy
sure sounds like my man Ryan has the
script I hope we scripted up a great
parlay actually I know he scripted up a
gray parlay we're going to speak things
into existence uh but let's Get on Up
out of here guys I think we're feeling
good but before we get out of here Ryan
what I know it's that time Ryan I know
you took it off for a reason
it's a parlay one more time of the
people that just joined it's just for
the people that just joined
who's just joining with two minutes left
in the show enjoy three four three this
is show business you never know
all right man I hate it but I'll do it
Giannis double double the Jared Jackson
three plus blocks Anthony Davis three
plus blocks and deared fox with a broken
finger under five and a half rebounds
four legs
plus four two five
this this is our week this is our time
this is give us a pep talk Ryan come on
let's go give it to him we've had months
of the losers Greg we've had rotating
casts rotating characters calling people
experts when they're not this we're back
this is us this is right we run this
Greg let's go
hey hey we run this on three we run
this on three one two three we run
this let's go hey we up out of here
on that note my name Greg Garvey Ryan
for Ryan MB let's go win some money man
let's go oh
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]